هل تعتقد طالبان أن الولايات
المتحدة قد هُزمت عسكريًا ، لقد
توصلنا إلى حلنا من خلال المحادثات ، وهذا
يعني أنه عندما تتوصل إلى حل من خلال
المحادثات ، فهذا يعني أنه وضع مربح
للجانبين ، فلماذا
تثق بك الولايات المتحدة الآن عندما تقول
ذلك  ستلاحق الآن القاعدة
وتطارد داعش لأن
طالبان سمحت للقاعدة بالعيش داخل
أراضيها في أفغانستان على
مدار العشرين عامًا الماضية ، ومن سياستنا أن
أي شخص يريد استخدام Scilab
أفغانستان لأهدافه ضد
الآخرين.  بلدنا وإلحاق الأذى
ببلدنا لن نسمح لهم عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالقاعدة ، فهل تدير
ظهرك لإخوانك المسلمين
لسنوات عديدة على مدى عقود عديدة لدعم
الولايات المتحدة ، وهي دولة مسيحية في
أمنها القومي ، فهذه مسألة
تتعلق  سياستنا التي تنص على أنه إذا قام شخص ما بإيذاء
دول أخرى من أفغانستان وعلى
أراضينا وأعلننا قانونًا
يقضي بعدم القيام بذلك ، فهذا يعني
أنه يتعين علينا  خطوات ake لمنعها